[Music]
so welcome to the session on stackdriver
I'm Audra hammer Lee and I like it when
people tweet at me during my talks my
Twitter is the underscore sagem Iser
which is spelled exactly as you think it
is and if you come up afterward I can
tell you the story behind that today
we're going to talk about stackdriver
so let's get a little bit of showing of
hands first figure out who all is in the
audience today
so who's used stackdriver before okay
awesome
who's using it in production right now
smaller site not surprising and who in
the audience has a DevOps Sidman IT ops
type of title ok smaller groups than I
was expected how many people who just
think of themselves as developers here
awesome ok so I work at Google as a
developer advocate but before I worked
at Google I worked in IT
ops DevOps whatever you want to call it
the title seems to change every week and
one of my Jobs was racking servers this
is not actually a picture of one of the
servers I rocked but many of mine looks
like this I also carried a pager for
about three years I was half of our
on-call team who here has done the pager
thing yeah not necessarily everyone's
favorite task and I did a lot of
production issue debugging including
connecting my trusty dead laptop to
production and I know I'm not the only
one who's done that even though it's a
bad idea so what am I talking about
stack driver one of the things I really
like about stock driver is that all the
tools come together everything is there
everything is integrated when I was
doing this work before Google I was
using one tool for log aggregation
another tool for crash reporting another
tool for application performance
monitoring and then a pile of tools for
monitoring pings Amanat all of the above
Nagios and whenever something went
really wrong everything would turn red
and it was really hard to figure out
what was actually going on because
everything was alerting simultaneously
it was also annoying when someone would
join or leave the team because I had to
grant them accounts on all of those
systems or take their accounts away when
they laugh
inspect driver does all of those things
it has a lot of that functionality
already built in and it's all integrated
so that's one of the reasons that I'm
super excited about stock driver but
I'll kick it up here and give you the
marketing pitch for an hour and we would
all get bored including me so instead
we're going to live debug a website
using the sack driver til chain while
I'm standing here so I made a simple
rails website running on App Engine flex
which we announced is now GA as of this
morning yes it supports Ruby this is my
website cat or not also known as pinned
/ and you can upload your cat you can
vote on the cat and you can see all the
cats and I'll give you a quick demo of
this so here's all the cats that people
have uploaded to tin / as you can see I
have some performance issues I baked
into this so we have stuff to look at
later but this is what happens when you
send an email to the entire team saying
show me your cats you know there's some
pretty cute ones you can look at and if
you wanted to upload a cat you can do
that standard basic upload form and for
voting on CAPS
these are the material design UI Oh
Chuck Norris in RAM though the picture
didn't load let's try a different one so
I can vote there they are that's all
there is to this website so here's the
basic architecture running it on App
Engine as I said which means I don't
care how many servers I have running App
Engine takes care of it
I wanted some sort of back-end
processing because I don't know any real
websites that don't have some sort of
back-end processing so there's a pub
sub-q set up behind this and when
someone uploads a cat it calculates
which cats still need more votes and
populates the queue and then when you go
to vote for cats it pulls from that
queue little contrived but you know demo
apps and then I'm using cloud sequel
running my sequel as my back-end so also
interesting I'm doing a talk to a bunch
of DevOps this has been people or people
who like to break things I hope
and I'm doing that talk it's really
boring if there's no load on my website
so I spun up a patchy bench and it is
currently hitting all bunch of URLs for
my website just do and get requests
relatively simple but it's better than
no load and that's running in the
background I'm running it on a compute
engine instance so let's say I'm taking
tens per to production I need some
monitoring and the first thing I need is
uptime monitoring one of my generals is
done with monitoring is I don't want to
monitor anything that if it goes wrong I
can't fix it so sometimes it's nice to
know things but if there's no direct
action you can take why do you want to
be broken up so let's set up an uptime
check actually gotten up ten check set
up this is going to be a very demo heavy
talk so I'm just using the standard
uptime check in stock driver for App
Engine we're going to look at it and
earlier today the Virginia site was
failing but now it's back up I can see
exactly where things are going on you
can also see a track of my response
codes this may correlate so when I
started up Apache bench and you can also
see my response latency and what's going
on this is all comes for free I just
clicked logged in to stackdriver for the
first time they're like you have an app
engine app in like yes yes I do and this
is the standard uptime check that comes
with App Engine so that's the basic
stuff done but I also want to check my
database and make sure that that's being
monitored so let's set up some monitors
on that cloud sequel so I can see you
how to spike up queries here and I
haven't had any queries recently that's
a little suspect so I'm going to set up
a new policy for that select metric
change on cloud sequel applies to all of
them and if my read ops decreases by 15%
over 15 minutes that seems like
something's probably not right
you only go up to 8 and I'm going to be
notified and they'll be notified as
sacrum Iser Google comm so now I've set
up a basic policy on my database if I'm
not getting enough read ups I'm assuming
that load has gone down for some reason
likely something's wrong the other kind
of thing I like to check when I'm doing
App Engine is I like to set up a policy
on the response codes I showed the graph
earlier where show I have a lot of 500
response codes there that's a little
suspect I probably should have gotten
alerted to that so I'll make a new
policy for that as well and it's
applying to my cattle or not which was
the other name format if 500 responses
are above will go with xxx xxx for a
minute 30 I want to be notified
you saw the blue line show up that shows
where that is so I would have been
notified earlier today if that had
happened and this time I'll have it
notify me with a console app name it and
now I've got two basic alerts show setup
that's not all stock driver can do one
of the many things I can also do with
error reporting and this is one of the
things I really like because if you set
up stock driver logging it pulls in the
logs and it analyzes them and finds
clusters of errors and lets you know
when things have aired out and it
doesn't show you the same error 10,000
times it groups them you dive in you can
see a simple trace of that and it
happens to be that my phone just alerted
so let's dig into it that may have been
planned so we're going to error
reporting see if the late
here this is the one I was looking at so
the one that the console app I have the
Google Cloud console app on my phone and
so I'm getting an undefined method pick
for fix number two and that seems ungood
and I got the whole stack trace here a
bunch of stuff and rails
how many rubyists rails developers are
having the audience I assume relatively
few more than I expected
yay Ruby and so some things I can do
when I get here I can link to the issue
if I had a bug tracker I can just put
the URL in here I can look at the raw
stack trace which may be more useful in
some languages I can see but it yo
you'll did a 500 message and that the
first one was seen 56 minutes ago and it
was seen in this particular app engine
version and I can actually make it
happen because I know how it happens or
it didn't happen that time but we'll dig
into it so now I know that I have this
error and I want to like sure look at it
in the logs and then my source I'll
switch over to the logs so I'm just
looking up stackdriver logging for my
Ruby app if you're using any of our App
Engine or client libraries it will
automatically show up to get all this
stuff working with Ruby I just installed
the stackdriver gem I didn't have to
actually do any configuration at all
it's just straight drop in and a lot of
the gem a lot of the libraries for web
frameworks work that way look at this
and I can also filter by log level
that's the cloud sequel database happen
I want error or above and I want my root
a plug so here's all my errors and I can
see them here as well this links to
error reporting
there's the error again I can mute in
there and so at this point I have a
pretty good idea of where this piece of
code that's failing in this is the point
where I normally drum pin to debug dr.
ever has a built-in debugger but it is
currently pre-alpha
for rails and I want to try it out this
morning it's not quite working so we're
going to actually drive straight into my
editor instead so welcome to Emacs so I
happen to write this this to do this is
broken and the issue I have here is that
I'm pulling all the votes from a pub sub
Q and I'm not actually refreshing that
pub sub Q except when people upload new
cats so if the queue empties I end up
pulling null and then I try to do a
bunch of stuff with no and that doesn't
work so well so what I need to do is if
there is no next cat next cat equals
cats cat dot all dot sample which in
Ruby just pulls me a single random one
from the whole entire list of cats so
now I've done that I'm going to deploy
to App Engine live because you know live
demos are awesome that's going to take a
little bit but I need to hit yes first
so we're going to back to the slides
here we go
so let's talk about some parts of the a
pinch of the sacrum every sweet I've
talked a little bit about monitoring I
showed you a little bit logging logging
can also export to bigquery I really
like bigquery a frequent link of talks
on bigquery because it's amazingly
powerful and I don't have to learn a
special query language to use it so if
you have a lot of logs and you're like
you know this interfaces and look
working for me to like dig in and the
regular stock driver logging interface
you can just export to bigquery and use
sequel or JavaScript to search your logs
talk a little bit about debugger one of
the awesome things about debugger is
that you can debug live on production
and it isn't like your normal stepping
debugger but it's still logically debug
live on production without connecting
your dev blocks to production which is
good in my world but the big thing I
haven't mentioned about stackdriver is
that it's cross Cloud most of the
features I've showed you work just as
well on AWS as they do on GCP I've
showed them on GCP it's GCP next but you
can also do all the monitoring all the
logging all the error reporting on AWS
as well or if you're one of those people
who's working in a cross cloud
environment which lots and lots of
people are now you can have all of your
information from both places in one
place you can set up the exact same
alerts for AWS and GCP at Google i/o
last year I had a database where my
master was running in gtp and I had the
replica running in AWS and I had all the
same alerts on both of them and the idea
was that it was a hot swappable setup so
if one of my two providers went down I
could switch and not lose as much and
not have as much downtime so other nice
thing about monitoring is we have
monitoring the setup for a lot of the
common open source tools this list is
not exhaustive but I've used it was
[ __ ] I've used it was memcache I've
used it was my sequel nginx Redis
RabbitMQ and often if you have these and
you have the agent running it will look
at the name of the instance and the
ports that are open and we'll make
available to you in the UI the metrics
that you are most likely to want because
it has a pretty good idea what you're
running if you're running my sequel you
have port 3306 I believe running and
it's named my my sequel instance it's
pretty sure that you're running my
sequel if it's wrong you can tell if
it's wrong but that's really handy and
it's fav
when you're setting stuff up also we
have metrics for a lot of our toolset
not surprisingly I showed you some of
the stuff for App Engine you can look at
reserved core CPU usage that kind of
thing we have our DAF protection you can
see if that's been triggered for compute
CPU utilization uptime read and write
bigquery
who here is a really good idea how to
monitor a giant data warehouse I didn't
and there's stuff we've built for
bigquery with the bigquery team that
makes sense so uploaded bytes scan bytes
how many queries you have going on I did
a blog post two weeks ago about
different ways that you can monitor big
query using stackdriver firebase super
popular awesome set of tools you can
monitor that as well and the stack
driver team and the kubernetes and
container engine team are working
together to build monitoring for
container based systems which is
something that a lot a lot of folks have
figured out exactly how to do yet you
want to know more about all the metrics
we have available URLs here this talk
will be recorded and online yesterday's
talks showed up before midnight last
night so 48 hours or less hopefully and
alerting so you saw me choose that I
could get emailed I got alerted by the
hit by the app on my phone I can also
get an SMS to my phone I've worked in
place with the youth page or Duty it we
can actress pager duty you can use slack
you can use hip chat you can use
campfire that covers a lot of the stuff
that people use for managing their teams
and figuring out what's going on in
places that they're looking for their
notifications we talked about error
reporting there's lots of great features
here and one of the other things I like
is that you can configure alerts and the
alerts automatically know when to stop
telling you about the same thing
happening over and over again not only
does it group it if you get over a
certain number of alerts in an hour it
shuts up because it figures you know at
that point and you're dealing with it
you just haven't been able to make
everything go quiet yet debugger I have
played with you bugger it's currently
available for Java go notice is beta and
python and it's not your normal stepping
debugger you upload your code or you
point the debugger at a cloud repo or
github repo you figure out the line of
code you wanted
look at you set a watch point and it
will catch an inflight request snapshot
at that point give you all the variable
values give you the stack trace and then
it'll let the request finish so then you
have all the details about what was
going on so if you have that situation
we're like okay factory says it's on
that line how the heck is it getting to
that line why does it have a null value
at that line I don't understand you can
set that watch point you don't have to
push an instrumented version of the code
you just do it live and depending on
exactly the run time you're running and
it adds some latency but not a heck of a
lot some of the languages are better at
handling that than others language
runtimes they're all different so I was
going to demo debugger I'll show you
what it looks like at least you can see
approximately what it would look like so
I'm going to oh you're doing things
wouldn't be a live demo if everything
didn't go exactly the way I wanted so I
have my cat we're not folder and here's
all my code and the controllers here's
the votes controller I was looking at
earlier there's the code that I've
changed already
and you can see that it does not
currently support the Ruby one time
actually have the debugger library the
gem installed but I'm not hitting a
staging version of our app because they
won't let me at this conference so I
can't actually show you live but it's
coming it's pretty also it should be
also soon but you can see how you can
just set a breakpoint in the side here
and get all the data of the app while
it's running live and you can see your
snapshot history you can also look at
your logs so the only thing I haven't
showed you yet is trace and I've done a
lot of work with a lot of different
tools that are trying to keep track of
my performance of my application while
I'm working on it and this one's pretty
awesome so I can look at a specific
trace for a specific request that was
slow
there we go and you can see that it took
312 millisecond it's not particularly
long but longer than I'd like most of
that was done in this new method which
is what I'd expect here was the sequel
portion where it was reading active
record doing the query here's the stuff
we're doing the rendering and you can
also look at the details the timestamps
trace time the untraced time what status
code it returned and a whole bunch of
other interesting things inside of the
response that it happened I can also
look at analysis reports so here's the
auto analysis for my route and this is a
latency over time 25 percent so you can
see the different graphs and seeing the
latency in milliseconds for the route of
the application at various times the 95
percent case and how it was doing a week
over week I believe this is what this is
cumulative distribution seeing different
ways of use of visualizing the same data
so one of the things you may have
noticed is that my show all tcats page
does not have any sort of pagination at
all and it is doing a pretty intensive
query because it is actually showing you
the cat's in order by most popular cat
and it's doing the averaging of all of
their votes in the database and so here
is all of the requests and the analysis
for all of my requests to slash caps and
see that this one was particularly long
I can click on it I can get the
information about that most of the time
was spent not in sequel actually looks
like it was waiting on the server but I
can also look at other requests that
took a long time showing render time
versus waiting time that was likely one
of the ones that was caught up while
apache ventures running and I get all
this summary information I can also
limit that URL by a pack by issue view
method by the status code if we had any
500s those five hundreds today and also
which parts of the service I've only got
one App Engine service and which
versions of App Engine I'm using I have
multiple versions so let's see if my
employment has completed it has so I'll
definitely do it it's all spinning
you can see the load on my app engine it
comes up you can do it wouldn't be a
live demo if it didn't go sideways so
you see how all the pieces fit together
while this is loading I'll demo when is
just a second when it loads that the
voting works again you've also seen that
I didn't maybe didn't see but I told you
and it really is true that all I did to
get all this instrumentation was quite
literally include gemspec driver in my
in my manifest to my gem file same thing
works with node and if the tools aren't
available yet for any of the other seven
languages that we support they're on
their way we're working on them right
now and I love that I don't have to
configure anything I don't have to
install an agent I don't have to like
get a set of keys for some third-party
service and make sure that the right
keys are on the production server and if
the devs don't have them so that the dev
data isn't for looting my production
data
everyone's accounts everyone's access is
controlled in one central place with I
am and it's all their ID all the basic
tool sets that I need are there and if
someone who has had to debug stuff for
ages upon ages upon ages before yeah and
the caps came up or when the current
winning cat is the animated gift cat so
everything's there everything's
everything's there and I don't have to
do a bunch of extra work for it so let's
see if we can vote on cats now that I
have fixed my bum oh and it even showed
me my cat that's Emma
one eight we'll see if it crashes and
the bug is fixed I didn't run out of two
links and it's randomized now so I want
to thank the team who helps Mario's his
talk and stuff is mine but I got some
help from the stackdriver team and
specifically was doctor of a ruby team
because i told them a month ago hey i'm
going to demo all your stuff on stage
you should probably get it done and they
had all the libraries done for me this
morning including the debug library and
it was my fault that it didn't get fully
included there's a bunch of resources
available if you want to learn how to
use this stuff here are a bunch of links
cloud google
calm / product names stackdriver
monitoring logging debugger error
reporting with an underscore trace
[Music]
[Music]